Congratulations, we're now at the end of this course. We're so proud
of you. It's been great to have you with us all this time.
>> You're well on your way to building
great applications that run in the Google Cloud.
>> But guess what?
>> We're going to be launching more courses about the Google
Cloud Platform so make sure you look out for those.
But in this course, you also saw how to build
a mobile app that can talk to your Google Cloud applications.
>> Talking of mobile apps, we're going to be launching
a course soon on how to build an Android application.
>> So make sure you look out for that one. But before we
leave you, just one final thing you have now seen what you can
do with App Engine today. Let's have Urs Hölzle a senior VP of
the infrastructure Google tell you about
the future of the Google Cloud platform.
So we're back here with Urs. In this course, we learned a lot about App
Engine. Urs, what can we expect from Google
Cloud platform and app engine in the future?
>> A lot of innovation because what I'm really most excited about is that
we're just at the beginning of something that I think is going to be really big.
>> You know, we're proud of what we have today but what we're
really aiming for is getting to something that five years from now is
so much better.
>> I think the rate of innovation that we're going to see in NetCloud
is going to pick up and we hope to be a big part of that.
>> But our goal really is to take what we have and make it so much easier to
scale, so much easier to program, so much easier
to be on mobile, so much easier to analyze data.
>> And then really get a platform for you
that is everything that it is today but much
much better.
>> Really to the point where, if you remember what you thought was
great today, we really have a great product that you know five years from
now you'll kind of remember and say wow, you know, I'm kind of, I was
naive to think that this was great because if I look at today's product.
>> You know, was really just the beginning of it that's what I'm most excited
about. Do you have any final words to the students that have now learned a lot
about App Engine?
>> Now that you know App Engine, you're actually in a great
position to try out other parts of our platform and one of the
things that we're really going to work on is make it very easy
to combine App Engine with VM's or would be Query or with storage.
>> So that you can mix and match and implement your application not just in
pure app engine but really combine in with any other part that we have in our
infrastructure and still have it be very easy for you to both
write and run that's the path we're on and I hope you
enjoyed app engine and you'll enjoy the other parts even more. That's
right. We've barely started on this
great journey to build Google Cloud applications.
>> So keep your coding fingers up to date and stay
on top of what's possible in cloud computing because day by day
the Google Cloud platform gets better and better. So you can be sure that you'll
always. Build the best applications when you run them on Google Infrastructure.
See you. [NOISE]